hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
high definition video tutorial and today
we're going to be checking out the new
youtube video editor this is the
built-in youtube video editor and this
is just going to be a quick overview of
it and i'm likely going to be doing
another video of it later once some more
features have been uncovered or when it
changes or something like that but i
just tweeted about this about three
hours ago and i took a deeper look at it
and i think it's worth a video so i'll
include the link to visit the youtube
editor in the description so this is the
interface itself and it has a couple
things that are very noticeable well
first of all the url which is uh uh will
be included in the description like i
said it has a tabbed interface so
there's a videos tab and an audio tab
and these will all be things that are
included of course in youtube's uh you
know things that you can overplay on
your music in case you don't want people
to hear the video you can always use
these built-in video tracks
you can also browse through my videos
and look through the videos you've
uploaded already to youtube and combine
them together all you have to do is
either hit the plus to add the video to
the storyboard or go ahead and drag a
video on to the the next square right
after it and i'll see the video gets
longer as i drag more and more clips to
the timeline now it's 8 minutes 50
seconds and i'll add try to add one more
and you'll see you can't go past
the 10 minute mark and it'll say total
duration is too long so we have to
remove or shorten a video clip so you
can remove any of the ones that you
entered
earlier just by hitting the x button
right there
so like i mentioned at the beginning of
this video it is an extremely simple
video editor you're not going to have
any transitions between videos but you
can actually cut things out and clip
them by using these scissors here so
let's say i want to scissor clip clip
part of this video out of course
hopefully this error won't occur all the
time we click the scissors and hopefully
you'll
actually be able to see a preview up
here and you can actually drag to clip a
part of the video that you want to be
included in the whole uh the whole
project you're making once you've made
this you can hit save and that right
there is the clipped part that you just
created so
hopefully it'll actually work maybe it
doesn't work in actually safari but
hopefully this will work in other web
browsers so once you've actually put
this all together we'll go ahead and
find select some audio uh we'll find
this one from offbench and again i'll do
a much more in-depth video
like this now this is from the audio
swap library so there will be ads on
your video uh but your since you're uh
you won't be making video average and
you won't be making money off of this
because uh whether or not you're a
partner this is audio swap content
so once you've put your video totally
together you've done all the clipping
that you want to do you can
go ahead and give your video a title so
i'll go up here and to the top and just
call it the title of the video and you
have all your clips at the bottom and
it's pretty much all set to go and you
hit publish now i'm not going to do that
because i don't want this to go up but
this is basically an overview of the
youtube video editor again you can check
it out maybe even publish something of
your own if you do come up with
something and maybe find some cool new
features or it changes in the near
future maybe want to make a video
response to this showing anything that
has been missed
so again we'll have a much more in-depth
look at this in the near future and
until then i'll talk to you guys in the
next video thanks for watching peace